the jurgen experience they're uh
they're doing an investigation of the
chain smokers
like the states involved in this
investigation because they did
essentially
a a car show where they they were on
stage
and there was like 600 cars in the
audience and they did their show
to people in parked cars like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with that
no why is that bad no i don't see a lot
of cars oh jesus
no there was no they were all standing
around oh
so it's supposed to be in cars and
people just said [ __ ] it let's get out
of the cars and stand
but play that play that let me see what
that is
oh jesus christ this is a dj
only a two second video so it depends
wow now it depends on intent i think
bro that's a concert it depends on
intent well
are there cars there was it a drive-in
concert
what does it say the crowd was estimated
at 2 000 for the concert at
water mill ticket prices range from 850
to uber vip options for 25 000
that accommodated rvs all profits were
earmarked for charity that's nice
city state of new york is now probing
the concert
are they probing looting to or just a
concert did they have uh
are they probing what happened in soho
or just uh just i had this
story too i saw recently i just want to
know i'm asking for a friend
700 person airbnb
mansion party flyers going around on
twitter for it
oh my god there's a thousand dollar
prize for a twerk contest
well it's hard to twerk but they're
saying that's like you know
a super spreader party or whatever of
course
yeah well i got those [ __ ] that say
oh
post malone's here at this nightclub and
i'm not even in town
yeah that's crazy right [ __ ] like
they're using yeah and they
people don't don't get their money back
right people pile into the club
it's so weird now i'm still curious
about that
the chainsmokers deal was it a drive-in
concert
supposedly they sold cars they sold cars
600 so that's not but that's not on them
if the people got out of the car right
that's the thing
like was it are you supposed to enforce
that
if they like say here's the thing if
they only had it set up as a concert
without
any enforcement whatsoever on how close
people stood to each other
right whose responsibility is it if
people get out and just start talking
right i guess this is what the
promoter either said i don't know if
they actually talk to them but this is
what they were supposed to have done or
did do
they were temperature checks upon entry
um no he said noted that concert goers
went through a temperature check upon
entry was not good enough really
offered hand sanitizer hey jerk off with
this
once parked and had restrooms that were
disinfected every 10 minutes oh
awesome well nine minutes it's giving
people cooties and then on the 10th some
dude comes in and hoses it down
told buzzfeed there were dividers
separating individual
parties in the pit area and that guests
were also instructed they would not be
allowed to leave their
desert designed well they've
misspelled must be designated but it's
designed
does uh for any reason other than to use
the restroom but obviously that's not
really what's going on but wait
what if if if if it's a drive-in show
why is there a pit right and also
that the dividers between people that's
horseshit [ __ ] the air doesn't give a
[ __ ]
if there's like a little piece of
cardboard here between you and the
people next to you
that your spit goes through the air and
it gets to them if you got it they got
it
i know and uh and i i
i don't think it has to do with the with
the boys in the group
i think it has to do with someone else
what do you think it has to do with
because i know the boys in the group
well it seems like sweet guys
i don't think it's their idea yeah
that's exactly what i think i think
right the total like it was a [ __ ] show
that just got out of [ __ ] hand
also here's the other thing if you get a
bunch of people in their cars drinking
and they're all able to open the door
and just socialize yeah they're gonna do
it yeah
and plus before that they're tailgating
right
so people are tailgating before the show
so they're cooking burgers having a
hangout having a good time having drinks
with each other
and then the show starts they're gonna
get out of their car and mingle with
each other they made new friends
you just pull up really close just touch
mirrors i mean there is a car a car at
least oh that's a car
dude what's the problem this article the
other one said that there was
it was safe they swear it was safe it
was safe
other video looked insane well
listen it seems safe if you get away
with it nothing happens
if you get away with it nothing happens
like oh my god it was so safe trust me
it was so safe
yeah you you get a covid test they find
you don't have it after you go to that
concert you go listen it was so safe
it was the safest it was not safe no one
even could see it you don't know if
someone has it
[Applause]